there are growing questions and we still
don't know the full scope of this about
what the hell were police doing during
the 40 to 60 minute period that the 18
year old duvalde texas shooter was in
the school now this is not about
criticizing police it's about thinking
critically
about the supposed solutions that
republicans say would be solutions we
need to think about whether that makes
any sense given what we are now learning
took place in uvalde texas we are now
learning
that while the gunman was inside the
school for 40 to 60 minutes after being
confronted by an armed officer
police were just outside
stopping parents desperate from going in
to try to stop the shooter now you could
say well those parents could have gotten
themselves killed true but what why were
why weren't the police in the school why
weren't the police actually uh doing
something during those 40 to 60 minutes
that would have had an impact
we now have footage
okay there is now footage
of armed police
outside the school during the shooting
pinning a man believed to be a parent to
the ground okay take a look at this
[Applause]
and you might so you see here police
have a guy pinned to the ground that's
not the shooter that's believed to be a
parent or some kind of school employee
desperate to go in and do something
because the police weren't
[Applause]
okay i think you get the idea
department of public safety director
steve mccraw told reporters that 40 to
60 minutes elapsed from when the gunman
opened fired until when the tactical
team got in and shot the gunman
uh
according to the two officials
the shooter went into a classroom and
locked the door
police on scene left him in there when
border patrol showed up they couldn't
break down the door and after 40 to 60
minutes a member of the school staff
unlocked the classroom door with a key
so we're still getting the details here
this is increasingly being looked at
what on earth happened but my point is
less about i mean listen we need to
investigate why police did what they did
there there are anecdotal reports and
it's still early
but there are anecdotal reports that the
reason it was border patrol ultimately
was that the police on scene were were
refusing to go in now that's just it's
an assertion that's been made and we
want to be really careful and make sure
we know what actually happened but the
question we need to grapple with here is
if this is what trained police did
how on earth do we think that armed
civilians in the schools are the
solution armed teachers
or armed janitors or armed lunch ladies
it doesn't make any sense and so we need
to figure out the specifics of what
happened here for sure
uh but there are a lot of other
questions that remain unanswered bigger
picture about what should be done if
you're using traditional toilet paper
and paper towels you're probably cutting
down trees from north american old
growth forest and i've talked about
before we don't want to be doing that
also they come wrapped in single-use
plastic that's also a mess
and the solution is real paper this is a
sponsor i feel great about real paper
makes paper towels and toilet paper from
fast growing bamboo not from virgin tree
fibers from forests using bamboo
prevents soil erosion it prevents
habitat loss and importantly it's a
major impact on carbon real paper also
uses no plastic packaging so we often
talk about what can we do
corporations need to do many things but
what can we do to help the environment
this is an easy thing and i made the
switch to real paper at home i can't
tell the difference everybody buys
toilet paper everybody buys paper towels
this is one you can actually feel good
about and you can use the code pacman
for 30 off your first shipment when you
sign up for a subscription at
realpaper.com
pacman the link is down below